we can't control what's going to be on
the board there's 31 of the teams
picking so
we just try to take advantage of our
opportunities in the draft to
improve our team however we can so
that's the way i've always approached it
i really can't
i can't
work on you any other way i i just you
know i don't feel comfortable going to
the draft saying well we're gonna
you know take one guy at this position
take another guy at that position
or you know like if it doesn't go that
way then
i just don't think you're getting the
value you know
for the picks that you have now look
we've all
you know made picks that worked out well
and we've all made pics that didn't work
out so well so it's it's an
inexact science and i'm not saying that
you know all the decisions are
you know have been good decisions or bad
decisions or anything else
and development's part of it too we
talked about that after robert kraft
said what he had to say about the recent
drafts of the new england patriots it's
not just the guys you take it's what you
do to make them into nfl players which i
think is part of what the patriots need
to fix but it is a crapshoot
it is inexact and he gave a a much
longer answer we just played part of it
they have a system that isn't just
grades they color code you know you have
to account for the fact
that your needs influence your
assessment right anyone who says we
always take the best available player is
lying right because the best available
player
your assessment of it is influenced by
what you need
and if you've got patrick mahomes and
the best available guy on your board as
a quarterback you ain't taking the
quarterback
unless you want patrick mahomes to
launch a passive aggressive effort to be
traded the following year yeah right
right yeah i mean it
it it has to match you know yes it's
it's about like what bill belichick is
telling you it's the value of the draft
okay we're picking
here all right we have this need right
but we have no player that's worth the
value
of the pick right here with that need
okay let's trade down
let's trade down and maybe the you know
trade down and now we'll address that
need lower down to where it meets
you know where the guys we have that
need graded are on our
on our chart right or you stay where you
are there and go okay we don't this
isn't our number one need
but it matches up with what we did what
what like uh
where we got these guys drafted and this
is our number two need
it's all about balancing that that's why
i find mike like their
second round pick christian barrymore
when when the patriots trade up
i i perk up a little bit because that
means to me
they had a guy there at pick 38 in the
draft
that he was sitting there and they
probably had him valued as one of the
top 20 players in the draft
and belichick sitting there or top 25
players in the draft where he's looking
at his board going wait
it's pick 38 we have this guy valued
here
what are we doing we got to make a move
up and go get him then if that makes
sense and the board must have told them
that because they're not the type of
organization that's really going to
stray
from their board their formula anything
like that and that's what's
you know made them miss at times but of
course has made them build a pretty damn
good football team for a long time as
well
barmore was a guy who was perceived to
be sliding because of some
issues yeah work ethic etc nick saban
came out and defended him last week and
nick saban's not going to put his name
on the line he doesn't right if there is
anything to it and
and that was good enough for bill
belichick he probably wishes saban
hadn't said anything about it publicly
but they were still able to get him
ernie adams
the director of football research i
think was the title but nobody quite
knows exactly what ernie adams did
other than get things official cia
member of the new england patriots
most impressive contribution super bowl
49
he was the one who spotted that shotgun
formation
double receivers on each side seattle
seahawks the tendency
in short yardage to throw out of that
set
so they had brandon browner that you
pick
you pick the the defensive back and the
other guys open on the end route
so brandon browner held the receiver
that was going to be
making the pick right allowing malcolm
butler to make the interception
yes and that was all er something ernie
adams found they practiced it
that week and then lo and behold you get
a super bowl ring out of it we'll never
have the full
totality of how great ernie adams was or
how special he was unless belichick
opens up the vault and lets us know all
the special things he does for that
football team or did for that football
team
i don't know i worked there for a year
and a half i got no clue exactly
he was in a room on the side mike i
think i've said this before
i used to love to go in there because i
knew he was working on some like
you know research project that was high
level and nobody else was supposed to
know and i'd walk in because i might
have to give them the practice schedule
or stuff like that
and he'd be like as soon as i'd walk in
he'd turn off his tv
and close his laptop and cover his notes
like it was some top secret mission he
was working on
so i always got a kick out of that but
uh great great part of that patriots
organization
why in the hell did they ever even hire
you they probably thought you were a
giant
spy i don't know
what i don't know maybe they were
feeding you false information that you
were running back to the new york giants
of all the teams
the only team that kicked their butt in
the super bowl before the eagles did
beat them twice and they get
there may be some higher level stuff
maybe ernie adams was not that smart
uh all right well and they're gonna have
to replace him now and that's really the
question where's the next ernie adams
come from
and do we see that manifest itself in
some slippage
in what the patriots are able to do how
much of the genius of bill belichick is
going to be peeled away by the absence
of that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports